.
"GUTFELD!" IS NEXT.
>> IN TERMS OF THE REDLINE THAT
YOU LAY DOWN, IS MILITARY
RESPONSE AND OPTION FOR A
RANSOMWARE ATTACK?
AND PRESIDENT PUTIN HAVE CALLED
YOU IN HIS PRESS CONFERENCE AND
EXPERIENCED PERSON.
YOU FAMOUSLY TOLD HIM HE DIDN'T
HAVE A SOUL.
DO YOU KNOW HAVE A DEEPER
UNDERSTANDING OF HIM AFTER THIS
MEETING?
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Greg: I DON'T THINK HE
UNDERSTANDS HOW QUESTIONS WORK.
♪ ♪
[APPLAUSE]
IT'S WEDNESDAY OR AS KAT LIKES
TO CALL IT BOB, WHY -- VODKA,
WHY AM I WAKING UP TODAY?
SHE REALLY SHOULD TAKE BETTER
CARE OF HERSELF.
[LAUGHTER]
GETTING WORSE.
HERE'S A FUNNY QUESTION.
IS IT WRONG TO BE AGAINST OUR
SIN?
YOU THINK GREG, THAT'S A DUMB
QUESTION BUT SETTING FIRE TO
THINGS IS BAD, VERY BAD.
UNLESS IT'S ONE OF HUNTER'S
PAINTINGS.
BUT WE SHOULD ALL CONDEMN ARSON,
CORRECT?
NOT SO FAST, HYPOTHETICAL VIEWER
I AM HAVING AN IMAGINARY
CONVERSATION WITH.
YOU HAVEN'T HEARD THE STORY OF
DANIEL ELDER, TALENTED ARTIST
SPECIALIZING IN LEFT-WING
RELIGIOUS MUSIC.
HE PUBLICLY SCOLDED ARSONISTS
AFTER A GEORGE FLOYD PROTEST IN
HIS HOMETOWN OF NASHVILLE THAT
TURNED VIOLENT, RESULTING IN
ASSAULT, VANDALISM OF THE
TORCHING OF AN HISTORIC
COURTHOUSE.
ELDER, VERY LIBERAL DUDE, POSTED
"ENJOY BURNING IT ALL DOWN, YOU
WELL-INTENTIONED BLIND PEOPLE.
I'M DONE."
SOUNDS LIKE WHAT I SAY AFTER I
USE THE BATHROOM.
SUSAN.
THEN HE DELETED HIS INSTAGRAM
ACCOUNT, AND THEN HE WAS DELETED
HIMSELF.
HE BEGAN THE NEXT MILE AND THE
ONLINE MOB CAUGHT WIND OF HIS
OFFENSE.
HOW DARE YOU CONDEMN VIOLENCE,
LAWLESSNESS?
THEY SPAMMED HIS FACEBOOK
ACCUSING HIM OF RACISM.
YOU DON'T EVEN NEED TO BE WHITE
ANYMORE TO BE A WHITE
SUPREMACIST.
YOU CAN BE A BLACK CONSERVATIVE.
IF YOU'RE ASIAN, IT DEPENDS IF
YOU'RE GETTING BEATEN UP OR
TRYING TO GET INTO YALE.
YOU CAN BE A CHRISTMAS TREE
FARM.
SOLIDAY, HOLIDAY TREE FORM.
ALL YOU NEED IS A PULSE ON A
WACKY DESIRE TO NOT SEE YOUR
NEIGHBORHOOD BURN.
THAT'S NOT WHAT THE STORY IS
ABOUT.
IT'S ABOUT CORPORATE COWARDICE.
WE SPEND A LOT OF TIME ON
CANCEL CULTURE.
THE MOB'S THIRST FOR SCALPS.
MY APOLOGIES TO LIZ WARREN.
THE REAL LIAR SHOULD BE DIRECTED
AT COMPANIES WHO WHEN FACED WITH
THE MOB TOSSES ESCAPE GOAT INTO
THEIR HANDS LIKE PONTIUS PILATE
HANDING JESUS TO THE ROMANS.
I AM REFERRING TO GIA.
IT STOOD FOR THE GREGORIAN
INSTITUTE OF AMERICA BUT NOW IT
STANDS FOR GROVELING IDIOTIC
[BLEEP].
IT'S LATEST PUBLISHERS.
I'M NOT GOING TO PRETEND I'VE
EVER HEARD OF THIS COUNTRY SO
I'M NOT GOING TO STAY I USED TO
BE A FAN.
BUT I AM NO FAN.
GIA IS AN OFFENSE TO GREGORIAN
MONKS.
THEY SHOULD HAVE TAKEN A VOW OF
SILENCE.
WHEN FACED WITH TEMPORARY ONLINE
BACKLASH, WILL DO GAVE YOU?
THE PRESIDENT.
THEY CONTACTED ELDER AND
DEMANDED AN APOLOGY.
HE DID NOTHING WRONG HE
ADMITTED.
THEY WERE SO SPOOKED ABOUT
LOSING MONEY OVER BOYCOTTS THAT
THE GREEDY CAPITALISTS WERE AT
THE APOLOGY FOR HIM.
"OVER THE WEEKEND I MADE A POST
THAT WAS INSENSITIVE AND WRONGLY
WORDED.
I DEEPLY APOLOGIZE FOR THE
ANGER, OFFENSE AND HARM THIS
CAUSED.
THERE WAS NO JUSTIFICATION FOR
MY POST.
SO RATHER THAN TRY TO OFFER AN
EXCUSE FOR WHAT WAS DONE, I
OFFER A PROMISE FOR WHAT I WILL
DO GOING FORWARD.
I COMMIT TO MAKING AMENDS AND TO
DIALOGUE.
I CONTINUE EDUCATING MYSELF
ABOUT PRIVILEGE AND BIAS.
MY WORK BEGINS NOW."
ALL THAT WAS MISSING, HIM
TELLING HIS FAMILY OF FAIR --
THEY ARE TREATING HIM VERY WELL.
ELDER SAID HE WOULDN'T DO THEIR
SNIVELING VOMITUS APOLOGIES OF
THE G.I. BACKED HIM UP AGAINST
THE TEMPORARY MOB, THEY CHOSE
THE MOB DROPPING HIM LIKE
BILL de BLASIO TRYING TO HOLD
A GROUNDHOG.
THEY TERMINATED THEIR
RELATIONSHIP OVER HIS INCENDIARY
REMARKS.
FUNNY HOW HIS INCENDIARY REMARKS
ARE WORSE THAN ACTUAL INCENDIARY
ACTIONS LIKE PERSON.
OUR JOKES ABOUT O.J. SIMPSON
WORSE THAN WHAT O.J. SIMPSON
DID?
ONLY IF JIMMY KIMMEL IS
DELIVERING THEM.
I WONDER WHAT THE ANGRY WHITE
MALE HAS TO SAY.
[METAL MUSIC]
[GREGORIAN CHANT]
SORRY, NOT SORRY.
♪ ♪
>> Greg: THE REAL STORY ISN'T
ABOUT CANCEL CULTURE.
WE TALK ABOUT IT A LOT.
MY HEAD HURTS LIKE WHEN KAT DOES
MATH OR METH.
IT'S ABOUT COMPANIES ABANDONING
YOU WITH THE SLIGHTEST NEGATIVE
PRESSURE.
IN EVERY CASE IN WHICH A
PERSON'S SACRIFICE TO THE HORDE,
WE ASSUME THE HORDE IS LARGE
WHEN IT'S ACTUALLY SMALLER THAN
AOC'S BOOK COLLECTION.
IT'S THE COMPANIES THAT ARE
LARGE BUT THEIR SPINES ARE AS
WEAK AS WEED WAS IN 1992.
YOU ONLY NEED A TINY MINORITY TO
DESTROY SOCIETY.
REVOLUTIONS ARE NOT UNLEASHED BY
THE MASSES.
THE MASSES DO IT TO THEMSELVES
WHEN FACED WITH AN IMMOVABLE
MINORITY.
THEY CAN BRING A COMPANY OF
THOUSANDS TO ITS GROVELING KNEES
BY SCARING THEIR COWARDLY EXECS.
IT'S A MICROCOSM OF THE
BLOODIEST REVOLUTIONS.
IT'S NEVER TENS OF MILLIONS BUT
A HANDFUL OF OVEREDUCATED
RADICALS WHO GET THE POPULATION
COWERING.
THEY RUN RIGHT THROUGH THEM LIKE
COVID-19 THROUGH A CUOMO RUN
NURSING HOME.
THIS IS THE BLUEPRINT FOR
REVOLUTION AND IT'S TEARING
THROUGH OUR EDUCATION SYSTEM,
GOVERNMENT AND BUSINESSES.
GIA SHOULD BE ASHAMED OF
THEMSELVES AND THEY SHOULD
APOLOGIZE.
I AM GOING TO DO IT FOR THEM.
WE ARE SORRY WE ABANDON ONE OF
OUR ARTISTS JUST TO PROTECT OUR
BOTTOM LINE.
IF JESUS CHRIST WERE ASKED ABOUT
THIS, WHAT DO YOU THINK HE WOULD
SAY?
IT WOULDN'T BE SORRY IF MY
REMARKS UPSET THE PHARISEES.
MAYBE SHE WOULD -- WE SHOULD
HAVE MORE MONEY CHANGERS.
YOU MIGHT SAY FORGIVE THEM
FATHER, THEY KNOW NOT WHAT THEY
DO AND UNDER HIS BREATH SAY WHAT
A BUNCH OF A HOLES.
WELCOME TONIGHT'S GUESTS.
SHE'S BROKE MORE GROUND THAN AN
ASTEROID THAT KILLED THE
DINOSAURS, FOX BUSINESS
CORRESPONDENCE SUSAN LI.
HE HAS A BRAIN LIKE EINSTEIN AND
ALSO HIS HAIR.
HOST OF JAMES ALTUCHER SHOW
PODCAST, JAMES ALTUCHER.
HE SPLIT MORE SIDES THAN A CHEAP
FRIEND AT APPLEBEE'S.
COMEDIAN TERRENCE K WILLIAMS.
SHE GETS HER CARDIO FROM FALLING
DOWN THE STAIRS.
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR KAT TIMPF.
I READ THIS STORY AND REASON,
GREAT STORY.
I DON'T KNOW WHERE HE GETS THE
ENERGY.
I HATE HIM FOR THAT.
SUSAN, YOU CLAIM TO BE AN EXPERT
IN BUSINESS.
>> Susan: I CLAIM.
>> Greg: YOU HAVE YET TO SHOW
US ANY PROOF THAT IT'S
DISAPPOINTING.
>> Susan: HARSH, HARSH.
>> Greg: I'M SORRY.
WHY DO YOU THINK CORPORATIONS
ARE SO QUICK TO GIVE IN TO THE
MOB?
THEY MUST KNOW IS NOT A LARGE
MOB.
>> Susan: I DID SOME HOMEWORK.
LAST ON THERE WAS HERE I SPOKE
TO MY MOTHER AFTERWARDS BECAUSE
SHE WATCHED THE SHOW AND SHE
HATES IT WHEN I TALK ABOUT HER
ON TELEVISION.
SHE LIVED THROUGH A HORRIBLE
TIME IN HISTORY CALLED THE
CULTURAL REVOLUTION.
THAT WAS A TIME WHEN YOU WOULD
POINT AND TATTLETALE ON PEOPLE.
TO PROVE YOUR OWN VIRTUOUS NEST.
THIS IS EXACTLY WHAT'S HAPPENING
ONCE AGAIN.
>> Greg: DID SHE NOTE THAT?
DID SHE SAY OH, MY GOD, THIS
DOESN'T LOOK LIKE A GOOD THING
IS HAPPENING?
>> Susan: THINK ABOUT WHAT
HAPPENED IN HISTORY.
LIVES WERE DESTROYED.
>> Greg: DO I LOOK LIKE
SOMEONE WHO WOULD THINK ABOUT
WHAT HAPPENED IN HISTORY.
CHAIRMAN MAO.
NOT A GOOD GUY.
HE >> Susan: NOT A GOOD TIME.
CANCEL CULTURE IS NOT GOOD.
>> Greg: JAMES, YOU'VE BEEN
THROUGH STUFF LIKE THIS AND YOU
OWN A COMEDY CLUB.
THIS IS KIND OF FRIGHTENING THAT
THEY WOULD THROW THIS GUY UNDER
THE BUS SO QUICKLY.
>> James: YEAH, PEOPLE SEEM TO
THINK THAT IF YOU EVEN SAY THE
WRONG THING, IF YOU THINK THE
WRONG THING THAN THEY HAVE THE
RIGHT TO DESTROY YOUR CAREER,
DESTROY YOUR PROPERTY.
DESTROY EVERYTHING.
DELETE YOU.
HERE'S A GUY WHO 50 YEARS AGO
EVERYONE WAS SAYING YOU CAN'T
BURN BOOKS.
NOW THEY'RE SAYING BUT IF YOU
CRITICIZE BURNING DOWN
COURTHOUSES, THAT'S FINE.
DON'T BURN BOOKS.
BURN COURTHOUSES.
WE ARE ALL COOL WITH THAT.
IF YOU DISAGREE, THEY'RE GOING
TO BURN YOU, LIKE YOU SAID.
TO SUSAN'S POINT, IF YOU LOOK AT
EVERY FASCIST MOVEMENT IN
HISTORY, IT STARTS OFF WITH
SOCIALISM.
THESE THINGS ARE CALLED NATIONAL
SOCIALIST MOVEMENTS.
MUSSOLINI'S ORIGINAL PARTY WAS
THE SOCIALIST PARTY.
THAT'S WHAT YOU'RE SAYING AND
THEY DON'T REALIZE THAT.
THEY ARE NOT BEING TAUGHT
CURIOSITY.
THEY ARE BEING TAUGHT OPINIONS
RATHER THAN FACTS.
>> Greg: IS HOW I MAKE MY
LIVING.
I DON'T LIKE THEM GOING AFTER
BOOKS OR COURTHOUSES.
IF THEY EVER GO AFTER YOUR
LUSCIOUS HAIR, I WILL BE THERE
ON THE FRONT LINES.
THEY'RE GOING TO COME AT YOU
WITH SOME CLIPPERS.
NUMBER THREE I WOULD IMAGINE.
>> Susan: THAT'S A CURLING
IRON?
>> Greg: I DON'T KNOW.
WHY ARE YOU MAKING FUN OF HIS
HAIR?
>> Susan: IT'S GORGEOUS.
>> Greg: TERRENCE K.
GIA'S BEHAVIOR, IT'S THE EXACT
OPPOSITE OF LIKE BEHAVIOR.
>> Terrence: I AM BOTHERED
RIGHT NOW.
I FOUND OUT I'M A WHITE
SUPREMACY.
I AM AT A LOSS FOR WORDS.
I'M AGAINST BURNING DOWN
BUILDINGS.
I'M AGAINST BLACK LIVES MATTER
BURNING DOWN BUILDINGS BUT TO
ASSUME IT'S RACIST TO BURN DOWN
BUILDINGS, YOU'RE SAYING THE
ONLY WHITE PEOPLE ON BUSINESSES
AND BUILDINGS.
SO THAT'S RACIST.
THERE ARE A LOT OF BLACK
BUSINESSES THAT WERE BURNED
DOWN.
THAT'S ACTUALLY RACIST BURNING
DOWN BLACK BUSINESSES.
I DON'T GET IT.
I HAVE A LOT TO FIGURE OUT TODAY
BECAUSE I DIDN'T KNOW IT WAS A
WHITE SUPREMACIST.
>> Greg: YOU KNOW WHAT'S WORSE
ABOUT YOU BEING A WHITE
SUPREMACIST, IT'S CULTURAL
APPROPRIATION.
YOU ARE TAKING IT FROM THE
ACTUAL WHITE SUPREMACISTS WHO'VE
BEEN WORKING SO HARD TO BE
BIGOTS.
>> Terrence: EXACTLY.
IF I HAD ON A RED HAT MY BURNED
DOWN A BUILDING, PLEASE BELIEVE
ME I'M GOING TO JAIL.
PLEASE BELIEVE ME I'M GOING TO
PRISON.
>> James: IF YOU WEREN'T
WEARING A RED HAT, YOU PROBABLY
GET OFF FREE.
>> Terrence: EXACTLY.
I MIGHT BURN SOME STUFF DOWN
TONIGHT.
BUT WHAT'S NEXT?
ARE THEY GOING TO ABOLISH THE
FIRE DEPARTMENT?
EVIDENTLY FIREFIGHTERS ARE
RACIST.
THEY ARE AGAINST OUR SIN.
THEY ARE AGAINST ARSON TRADING
>> Greg: EVERYTHING IS RACIST.
KAT, ARE YOU GOING TO JOIN ME
AND BOYCOTT LEFT-WING SOCIAL
JUSTICE LITURGICAL MUSIC.
>> Kat: I'VE BEEN BOYCOTTING
THAT FOR YEARS.
IT'S AN EXAMPLE OF
CANCEL CULTURE.
IT'S SO OBVIOUS.
I THINK THIS IS ALSO AN EXAMPLE
OF THE CONSEQUENCES OF OUR
CURRENT WIDESPREAD BINARY VIEW
OF POLITICS WHICH IS SOMETHING
THAT I HAVE EXPERIENCE FOR A
WHILE.
I DON'T HAVE VIEWS THAT FIT INTO
EITHER MAJOR PARTY.
IF I ESPOUSE THE VIEW FROM ONE
MAJOR PARTY PEOPLE ASSUME I
AGREE WITH EVERYTHING.
THAT'S WHAT HAPPENED TO THIS
GUY.
HE SET I DON'T LIKE THESE PEOPLE
BURNING DOWN THESE BUILDINGS.
THEY ASSUME THAT HE ALSO
BELIEVED THAT THE PROTESTERS WHO
WERE PROTESTING PEACEFULLY WERE
DOING THE WRONG THING, THAT HE
COULD NOT SUPPORT THAT MOVEMENT
EVEN THOUGH THOSE THINGS ARE IN
NO WAY EXCLUSIVE.
YOU CAN BE AGAINST ARSON BUT
ALSO SUPPORT THE MOVEMENT
AGAINST RACIAL INJUSTICE AND FOR
POLICE REFORM.
I'VE SAID FOR A WHILE THAT WE
NEED MORE INDEPENDENT THINKING.
I THINK WE NEED TO TAKE SMALLER
STEPS NOW AND JUST SAY OKAY.
WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO RECOGNIZE
THE POSSIBILITY THAT INDEPENDENT
THINKING MIGHT OCCUR IN
SOMEONE'S HEAD.
WE CAN JUST START THERE BECAUSE
THIS IS NOT SOMETHING THAT HAS
HAPPENED TO THIS GUY.
IT'S HAPPENING ALL OVER THE
PLACE.
IT'S DUMB BUT IT'S NOT LOGICALLY
CORRECT AND IT CREATES DUMB
NARRATIVES.
DOME IS BAD.
>> Greg: YOU HAVE BEEN
WATCHING A LOT OF "THE VIEW."
>> James: MAYBE THEY GOT RID
OF HIM BECAUSE HE'S A BAD
MUSICIAN.
>> Greg: THAT COULD BE THE
UNSPEAKABLE TRUTH.
>> James: YOU'RE A RACIST.
BURNING DOWN RIGHT NOW AS